les grandes villes comme montréal semble
être d'un prenable forteresse pour les
conservateurs et millions d'électeurs
leur échappe dans la métropole
quand et aussi longtemps qu'on se
fermera sur certains sujets importants
comme l'environnement
on va avoir beaucoup de difficultés je
pense à attirer la clientèle jeune dans
nos villes l'ancien ministre
conservateur michael fortier ne sera pas
de la course à la direction
il juge ses chances de l'emporter était
trop mince
certaines de ses positions trop éloignée
de la base du parti
moi je serais en faveur d'une taxe sur
le carbone je suis en défaveur de laissé
trop de liberté nos députés de déposer
des projets de loi pour changer des
listes les sujets qui ont été décidées
depuis longtemps au canada que ce soit
l'avortement ou le mariage entre
personnes du même sexe
il espère néanmoins que ces débats
importants auront lieu entre les
candidats et on peut pas revivre
le cauchemar
l'automne dernier notre pays or les
principaux candidats ont utilisé les
premières semaines de cette course pour
se présenter sur les réseaux sociaux
deux jours exceptionnels au québec ils
sont unanimes
pas question d'imposer une taxe sur le
carbone ils défendent aussi à l'unisson
l'industrie pétrolière albertaine leurs
attaques sont dirigées contre justin
trudeau
justin trudeau doit s'occuper de ceux
qui menacent notre économie je pense que
c'est un groupe assez homogène deux
candidats deux candidates
l'ancien chef de cabinet d'un juge ils
plaident depuis quelques mois pour un
grand brassage d'idées qui n'aura
peut-être pas lieu parce que la course
sera très courte
ça fait en sorte que tu as pourtant
d'aller chercher non plus des nouveaux
membres conservateurs donc tu t'adresses
vraiment peut-être aux cent mille cent
cinquante mille membres conservateurs
qui ont une carte dans leur poche
s'adresser uniquement à la base peut
être une stratégie périlleuse selon ce
professeur de sciences politiques en
alberta c'est ce à quoi on s'attendait
avec un brochet c'est à dire oui parle
aux conservateurs sociaux et religieux
mais par la suite il faut changer son
discours en est on s'est aperçu que par
la suite il n'a pas été justement en
mesure de changer son discours de
manière efficace
le parti ne pourra toutefois pas évité
les questions sociales qui avait plombé
la campagne électorale d'un joe scheer
au moins une candidate
l'avocate torontoise naisseline luis a
reçu l'appui de la coalition pour la vie
un mouvement anti avortement qui compte
se faire entendre
il suffit de bain sont choisis radio
canada ottawa